the USS Gerald r4 name for the 38th
President is taking shape Huntington
Ingalls Newport News Shipbuilding
progress this is it welcome to the
bridge captain John Mayer the Fords
first commanding officer took me on a
tour I like the view he'll be
responsible for more than 4,600 sailors
who serve on the most expensive warship
in history virtually every system on
board the ship is either dramatically
improved or wholesale and completely
brand new to this class of ship all the
innovation meant to boost productivity
while at sea
our primary objective to start with was
to increase the capability of the
platform and decrease the Manning on the
ship the biggest change is a redesigned
flight deck there are three aircraft
elevators instead of four separate
helicopter landing pad and a first of
its kind electromagnetic catapult system
instead of steam the changes will allow
the four to launch 25% more flight
missions a day than on a nimitz-class
carrier the ability to get the aircraft
back in the air rearmed that makes all
the difference in the world
big changes below the flight deck as
well next summer we'll have sailors pack
in this place eatin breakfast lunch and
dinner new nuclear reactors and other
upgrades will produce 250 percent more
power
goodbye steam pipes in hydraulics hello
14 million feet of electrical and fiber
optic cable this is really designed for
aircraft that aren't even on the drawing
board yet the forge crew will be 25%
smaller than on current carriers they'll
enjoy more air conditioning than ever
before the living accommodations here
are much much better all of this comes
with a steep price tag the ship is 22%
over budget and six months behind
schedule
what are taxpayers getting for their
thirteen billion dollars first thing I
would say is you're getting a 50-year
platform I can tell you that in 2065
this ship will still be doing the things
the taxpayers of 2065 needed to need it
to do but do American taxpayers really
need eleven
carriers that's a question Congress will
have to answer as the Ford prepares to
enter the fleet everybody wants one
we've got them why would we even think
about having less